Let’s talk about what’s probably the best chance
we’ll ever get to save the planet
and ourselves.
And we know it’s a mess but for a while there
nobody was driving or flying, factories shut down.
Our carbon footprint shrank a few sizes.
But now — now the global economy
is chugging back to life.
And all those people pushing for a sustainable future?
Well they’re warning we can’t go back to business as usual.
So how did the pandemic affect the environment?
And is it possible to bring back the economy
without killing the planet?
With COVID-19 the Earth basically caught a break.
And maybe we have too.
For starters the global shutdown
did a lot of environmental good.
People noticed.
It happened fast.
Almost overnight cities like Beijing and New Delhi
which usually choke on smog
were able to enjoy baby blue skies.
Bees could smell flowers and find food more easily
because of less car fumes.
Deserted streets also meant some wild animals
made a bit of a comeback.
Though the return of swans and dolphins to Venice
well, that was fake.
But still…
Over the last decade CO2 emissions have been rising
around 1% every year from things like cars
planes and factories.
But all of that activity ground to a halt during the pandemic.
And experts think that by early April
global CO2 emissions had decreased by around 17%.
But it’s not all been rosy.
Billions of us have been told to wear gloves and masks
wear more protective gear.
And it’s all piling up on the mountains of garbage
we’re already dealing with.
Animals that were protected because of tourism
and the money that came with it
suddenly became targets for poachers.
And the world lost more rainforests.
In March it was more than twice the monthly average.
That standstill is now starting to
look more like a slow shuffle.
Lockdowns are lifting, economies are
powering back up again and emissions are returning
to pre-pandemic levels.
Which is worrying because even before this crisis
we had ambitious climate goals.
And we’re behind.
Right now the rise in global temperature
is around 1 degree Celsius above pre-industrial levels.
And we’re already feeling it.
There’ve been more wildfires, longer droughts.
The storms are crazy.
Ice caps are melting, sea levels are rising.
But we’re on track to hit a 1.5 degree rise by 2030
and soar past that if emissions keep going up.
Now even half a degree may not sound like much
but it’s a world of difference.
At a 1.5 degree rise the Arctic Ocean would be ice-free
at least once every 100 years.
At 2 degrees  that’s once every 10.
At 1.5 degrees sea levels would be 10 cm lower
by the end of this century
than they’d be with a 2 degrees hike.
Coral reefs, well, they’re in bad shape regardless.
To stop that happening we need to
get carbon levels down.
A growing number of countries and companies
are signing up to the goal of zero carbon by 2050.
That means cutting emissions but also finding ways
to remove carbon from the atmosphere
until the net gain is zero.
And to do it in 30 years.
But these aren’t normal times.
Which is why this is seen as an opportunity.
What if we don’t fully go back to our old ways?
What if, as people in the climate-change business
are saying, we rethink how we recover from
this economic meltdown.
Cities like Milan, Athens and London already have plans
to reallocate street space from cars to cycling and walking.
As in politicians resistant to green policies
which for climate scientists is a problem.
Because what they all say — over and over
is that to stop climate change we have to think big.
Azhar is talking about gross domestic product.
Which is the total value of the goods and services
produced by a country usually measured over a year.
The more GDP grows
the healthier that economy is seen to be.
And that model has lifted
hundreds of millions of people out of poverty.
But the cost to the planet isn’t factored into GDP
things like pollution, climate change
and the planet’s resources.
It’s why economists say that model isn’t sustainable.
But a lot of people say we don’t have to go there.
Climate activists and economists are pointing
to trillions of dollars on the table right now
that governments have earmarked
to revive economies.
It’s a huge amount of emergency cash.
The point they’re making is some of that money
being used to recover from the pandemic
could be used to avoid an even bigger catastrophe.
Obviously nobody wants that to happen.
And right now there’s money and opportunity
to make sure it doesn’t
on a scale none of us have ever seen.
So you kind of have to wonder whether this is
our last best chance to get it right.
There’s plenty going on in the world
so if there’s a story in the news that’s complicated
and you want us to explain it let us know.
and make sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
so you don’t miss our next episode.
I’ll see you next week.